[Music]  foreign  I have someone who has a special talent  for these kinds of things we call them  the alpha right the dog no  like a wolf  heal you could play tomorrow night  gotta be willing to learn cancel my two  o'clock and to hold on my calls are you  gonna be in a meeting  yeah kind of  she's here too  [Music]  the feeling the answers are in Beacon  Hills I haven't been back in a long time  [Music]  how do we know she's really Allison who  are you it's me it's Scott  who  whoever or whatever is out there right  now  it's not Allison  we need everyone  there's not going on and I think it's  all connected  the nicotine has come to play a new game  remember who she was  like he's knocking pieces off the board  so how can we put me back on him  [Music]  okay  I'm still standing  I'm still the alpha  sounds does a wolf make when it's going  to die